welcome to hannity tonight two major new
endorsements for president donald trump
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
openly dreaming about
raising your taxes through the roof
bolshevik bernie sanders once again
heaping
massive praise on joe biden's hard
left turn and bernie admitting biden is
not
now a radical socialist like him
we have a mini monologue coming up
tonight on that and so much more but
first
our top story takes us to portland
oregon
yeah another liberal city we've run by
liberals for decades
unlawful violent riots are turning the
city into a literal
disaster area and yeah it looks like a
war zone like other
places for months portland has been
ripped apart by a group of malicious
so-called anarchists
three federal courthouses have now been
damaged on multiple occasions
the hatfield courthouse was fire bombed
the u.s
custom house was vandalized police were
attacked with lasers
several officers now assaulted with
sledgehammers
stores were broken into buildings were
set on fire
this is insane we're talking about
dozens and dozens of assaults arsons
graffiti
looting vandalism violence you name it
so-called demonstrators even attempting
to set up their own autonomous zone
just like the chop chaz summer of love
spaghetti potluck dinner zone in seattle
and so far businesses in the downtown
area of portland
they have reported at least 23 million
dollars in financial losses
here's just a small sample of what is
taking place there on a daily basis take
a look
on the sidewalk
this has now been going on for more than
six straight weeks across the country
12 dead police officers 1200 injured
and rocks and bricks and bottles of
molotov cocktails
you want to be a cop in portland tonight
not only are
portland's far left city leaders letting
this happen
they're actively shunning any and all
help from president trump
just like seattle just like chicago and
just like new york now
how have things worked out in those
three liberal-run cities for decades
in fact when the dhs deployed federal
law enforcement officials to protect the
city's federal buildings
they were accused of quote acting like
an
occupying army mayor ted wheeler
demanded that the federal agents quote
follow local rules all while rioters
were acting with impunity
wheeler went on to then tweet the best
thing they can do is stay inside their
building or leave portland all together
and in the meantime i asked them to
clean up the graffiti on local federal
facilities
wow